I think one of the big barriers to
really having a felt sense of being one
is is the inability to love yourself and
to accept yourself for who you are
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin we are now in
our second annual partnership with the
transformative technology conference we
are now going to be talking about
emotional fitness we have dr. cynthia
phelps joining us on the show hello
thanks for coming on the show my
pleasure
really appreciate him super pumped to
talk to you about emotional fitness is
so much more let's jump into things with
one of our favorite subjects to talk to
our guests about does it
are we really all one that is my
personal spiritual view now how much I
can execute that on a daily basis do you
know really varies but that is my core
belief and that the more that we can
break down the barriers between us and
see the other as the same we're going to
be able to move past kind of our tribal
nature and and solve some serious
problems what has been your relationship
with diving deep into that
interconnectedness you know I was raised
as a presbyterian and trained as a
scientist and so interconnectedness was
not really something that was on the
forefront but I remember I was in a
bookstore and I ran across this little
little blue book and it was called
present moment awareness and it was kind
of like I had just discovered something
that I didn't know that I didn't know
and that was kind of like my first
realization that there was something out
there spiritually that I had never
explored before present moment awareness
yeah I don't even know who wrote it I
still have the book though yeah but it
started my journey basically yeah my
spiritual journey for myself yeah and so
then talk to us about how present moment
awareness ended up really jump-starting
that and also what have been these like
main
moments for you with feelings of
interconnectedness with egodeath with
all these different ways of tapping into
that feeling of oneness yeah so I think
it was probably your own 2004 ish that I
ran into that but maybe more like 2002
now that I think about it and it was one
of those things where the words in the
language was very foreign and I really
wasn't able to execute on it until much
later and in fact I had experienced a
series of traumatic events some some
pretty serious personal loss and I went
through a period where I was coping with
alcohol and if I'm gonna be honest I was
an alcoholic and so I went through this
I went through rehab and that didn't it
didn't really fix my problem because my
my core problem inside of myself was
shame and I had this inner narrative of
shame like I'm weak because I have a
mental illness
I'm squandering my opportunities these
types of shameful inter- 'z were in my
head and so but I had this amazing
experience in it probably the most nerdy
enlightenment moment I was reading a
research article on self compassion and
I realized like like this is the thing
that's really going to change my life
like the what the research shows is that
this is the missing piece in my life and
it was at that point that my life really
began to change and that was almost
seven years ago now almost exactly whoa
and so then how did it how did you work
on the habits the patterns the feelings
that ended up moving you away from shame
and towards the present moment awareness
well first I want to acknowledge that
I'm still working on it
yeah always a work in progress always I
think so for sure yeah
perpetual kindergarten as oh I like that
because because the way you learn and
can do
is by playing right I love that right so
you know I was trained as a scientist
I'd love to figure things out I'd love
to put the puzzle pieces together I see
things and systems and I'm also a
teacher you know I really love
explaining things to people and so as
soon as I started studying
self-compassion I wanted to teach it to
other people because I I just I couldn't
hold myself back and actually before
that a funny antidote was that when I
first found the research and self
compassion I probably spent this is kind
of embarrassing to say but probably
three months studying self compassion as
if studying it would somehow going to
magically make me self compassion it was
until like I had it a second i'll jamón
I was like oh oh like I need to practice
this stuff and so you know I'm right I'm
a little slow but I get there and that
this was the big thing of practice of
compassion correct towards yourself yeah
what was that like yeah break this break
it down you know at first it was it was
a relief
because I had found something that I
knew was going to fix me and in in such
a profound way that like I said a sober
date and never looked back and in it was
honestly much easier than I had thought
it was going to be now granted I had
gone through a stint of rehab and so I
kind of knew logistics of being sober
how to arrange my life to do it but but
I hadn't treated the shame right and so
it was maybe my sober date is January
1st and so it was what year was that
2013 2013 Wow
so approaching seven years now Wow
it's very exciting and
so I remember they still in San Antonio
is it's it's a very big party City and
so they always have those very
threatening ominous like drive drunk
you know clever slogans that are still
up over you know past the holidays and
it was like I was sober not I think for
a couple weeks at that point and I
remember driving under one of them and I
had this feeling like I never have to
worry about that ever again and it was
like such the opposite of what I thought
recovery was gonna be you know I just
had it in my mind I think that it was
just gonna be this like white-knuckle
like gotta get through it got to use a
lot of grit you know and it really ended
up looking a lot different and then now
I want to ask you also about you know
you have this beautiful journey of
yourself being able to get through
something as challenging as an addiction
to alcohol and also just getting through
shame and connecting more deeply to the
interconnectedness of all to this one
then how about for all these other
instances of you now having this
trajectory have you you know seen this
more with your friends that you are
surrounding yourself with in their
stories and what do you and now tell us
more about this these these this idea of
us all really being one so I think one
of the big barriers to really having a
felt sense of being one is is the
inability to love yourself and to accept
yourself for who you are because it that
puts up a barrier to being able to
accept another person for who they are
mm-hmm and so you know my journey so
much of it is about letting that go
constantly practicing self-acceptance
and self you know self compassion and
love myself especially during the times
where I feel like I'm suffering or I did
something stupid or you know where where
the judgment comes up for me that has
been the way that I have been able to
connect with people and a more deep way
and actually have much more deep
friendships with individual people but
also you know sobriety in itself I think
is very has helped you have a
clear-headedness totally that maybe you
didn't have before in you really can
kind of see yourself and your own
patterns and your own behaviors and the
things that are keeping you in the
thoughts that are keeping you away from
not being connected with everyone else
you know because I mean it's easy to
have a philosophy or a religious view
that we're all one right but showing up
every day in that space as much
different it's much more challenging
yeah
showing up every moment of life in that
space is so fascinatingly challenging
and beautiful to go through that process
of every breath of air every moment of
time every bite of food simple water
interaction with another human and
you're right this first barrier in many
ways is this idea of how much do we love
ourselves how much self compassion have
we done self-love have we done know
thyself have we done and then heal
thyself as well yeah and without that
then we can't actually see other people
for who they are for their beautiful
albeit there are cards that are dealt on
all of our hands that can we see those
traumas as treasures and all this type
of stuff so let's do emotional fitness
so this is obviously something that's
the probably one of the most pressing
issues of our time today it
especially going into the exponential
technology age and also having the super
ridiculous unprecedented computational
capacities in our pockets now it used to
never be that we could be distracted so
easily as we can today and the business
plans behind the attention economy are
also causing mental health issues did we
see things like suicide rates and
depression ain't saying anxiety rates
but it's so fascinating that technology
can also be a solution but also these
feelings of interconnectedness like
nature therapy like do we have to really
try and say like science owes nature
therapy it's like no like really first
principle like duh and and yes so
there's obviously non tech solutions to
get towards interconnected feelings but
let's talk about your work as
specifically with inner allies
specifically using technology to help
augment mental health and emotional
fitness walk us through your fascination
with this and what this all is well
honestly the the kind of core practices
that I want to put into the applications
that we're building Center around self
compassion and so you know there's
sixteen years of research and self
compassion now and one of the
interesting things that has emerged is
that there's actually people that are
very resistant to self compassion and
there is it's kind of like self
compassion has a branding problem do we
know why they're resistant oh there is
probably some connection with you know
some of their childhood experiences
where it's not okay to feel loved and
that puts you in a unsafe space you know
what I mean so you might have had an
experience where you were hurt while
you're you know experiencing that
feeling and so but even people that
maybe we can't trace it back to any kind
of trauma often times you say self
compassion they'll say oh it's going to
make me narcissistic or
gonna make me weak or it's going to you
know it's gonna have some kind of neck
like if I'm self-compassionate then I'm
just gonna sit on the couch and eat ice
cream all day like you know and so but
when you look at the research literature
and not how people feel about the term
we actually know that people who are
more self compassionate are more
productive they tend to be better at
changing health behaviors you know
they're more innovative like the list
kind of goes on and on mm-hmm yeah and
so what I saw was this problem is in
another another issue is that right now
self compassion is largely being taught
in an eight-week class very similar to
mindfulness based stress reduction and
the classes tend to be filled with
people who look almost exactly like me
middle-aged white women and so I saw
both of those problems I was like you
know this stuff is so powerful and so
life-changing like we need to bring it
to everyone we need to solve the
branding problem around it around self
competitive self compassion yeah it was
a branding problem around self
compassion and then the democratization
of the technology into the hands of
people that need it across all ages and
all cases where it's never been heard of
or they have heard of it and all these
different entry points exactly well and
so my solution actually doesn't have to
do with digital technology it's a really
a process and so one of the things you
know that I spoke about just a bit about
was I had this very shameful inner
narrative and so one of the practices of
self compassion is to be able to take
your narrative and make it kind and
supportive right and so when I first
started practicing self compassion it
was pretty easy for me to kind of weed
out those toxic narratives you know they
were not too hard to find but when I
tried to kind of place in my self
compassion yeah
yeah it was like a void I did not have
the language of self-compassion and in
fact when I tried to do it you know like
followed the rulebook if you will it
felt awkward
I felt embarrassed and I was doing this
all in my own head so I thought you know
interesting if I'm having this
experience of the trying to practice
this this powerful inner narrative
practice of compassion
I bet other people are having the same
experience just not having the language
and then feeling really awkward about
practicing it and so what I created was
actually a cast of characters called the
inner allies and they are based on
something called core emotional needs
and so this was defined by something
called schema therapy and it's a portion
of schema therapy that helps you
understand what a person is kind of
needing in their life and so it was
based on they basically took people who
kind of came in for psychotherapy and by
more-or-less their early childhood
experiences put them in these different
buckets and so like maybe you had the
bucket where you didn't receive a lot of
nurturing and love and then so your core
emotional need would then be nurturing
our love and do they have to submit
answers to questions that you posts for
you to gain a psychometric analysis I
can yes and that is something I'm
actually working on it's actually very
different than something like an anagram
or a personality test of some sort
because those tell you who you are where
the inner allies like the team that you
might want to build to how to support
yourself they tell you what you need how
do you figure out what inner allies to
give them like so how do you how do you
prompt them to parse for their needs
right so there is a variety of ways to
do it and so we can take those schema
therapy buckets and create questions to
try to find out if people had some of
those childhood experiences that were
troubling so they do go answer
about potentially troubling childhood
experiences yes but in a way that's not
very invasive you know so we're not
asking details so uh you know to be I do
coaching with people one on one and I've
been doing that with my and kind of
honing this inner Ally process over the
last three years or so and I'm actually
really in the beginning stages of
getting implemented in a digital
technology form I don't have had a few
kind of tries and and failures and kind
of learned a lot out of the process but
one of the things that I've been doing
all the time in the background is just
really working on this process of how
how to actually work with people who who
have the same kind of inner narrative
difficulties right and so there's a
variety of ways of going about it you
can go about it like what kind of
childhood issues did they have you can
look at from a cognitive behavioral
therapy standpoint there are some what
they call difficult thought patterns and
you can kind of weed out and then
address you also can do a meditation
with people a couple of different
meditations one where you actually walk
them through like what is a core
emotional need and then get them really
still and kind of go in and ask like
okay what do I what is it that I really
need and then kind of drop them deeper
and be like okay what is it that I
really really need and so that's a
really good starting place to choose an
inner ally and there's also doing it
within a relationship and this is
another meditation so you're not
actually with another person but you
think about a situation that was
troublesome that you had with somebody
who was close to you
it could be a work colleague it could be
a family member and you take yourself
back to that difficult situation where
maybe you were hurt or you had some kind
of difficult emotion around it right
and then you drop into you take them
through a process which ends and
basically like what did you need in that
moment like what what would you want to
have had that person say or do for you
and that's another way to reveal like
what are some of the core emotional
needs that we really want there's a lot
of time that's what happens in in in in
a relational conflict is like you know I
say hey do you want to go out to dinner
and you say oh no I have to work and
then I'm sad because what I really
wanted was connection yeah but I didn't
say like hey would you like to connect
and then in that case you'd be like I
would love to connect you right after I
do this work right and so and so we
typically don't relate that way because
we don't really come to the
relationships knowing what our core
emotional needs are that's why I you
know in the in my awareness around core
emotional needs is key and the way to it
the way to engage with another family
member spouse or a partner or yourself
yourself friends etc in a way that is
conducive to being aware of your core
emotional needs and is efficacious is
paramount and emotional fitness it's so
interesting are so many questions I want
to ask you about this you gave this
example at the beginning this idea that
it's easy for someone to easier for
someone to reflect in and see like a
negative behavior pattern and to be like
okay I understand that may be extremely
poor eating habit or not exercising for
extremely long periods of time we're
sleeping really poorly over and over
again is not good for me
so I will work on siphoning that back to
a great state but then this idea that
maybe implementing some sort of a self
compassion thing into my routine like
literally if I'm like in a workflow for
a couple hours and it's like being like
get up and stretch and it's like well
but I'm in such good flow at work and so
I have to you know get up with
do that or there's that part was really
interesting to me about how to actually
make these augmentations in people's
emotional Fitness and then the other one
that came up was what exactly do these
like inner allies what do they do for
you know after you gain some knowledge
about about my emotional needs then how
do these allies come up in my life and
say you know Alan it's time for some of
that emotional need you know how does
that actually how does that happen
question so you know and each inner Ally
we have kind of stalked with a bank of
compassionate language that centers
around that core emotional needs so
they're kind of like a cheat sheet for
how you can begin to talk to yourself
and so when I use the cards I I have a
card and it has inner Ally on the front
and on the back it has its lined and so
what they do what I do in coaching is we
have them actually customize their own
phrase on the back because it's it's
really important to have the language
that hits your heart like when it hits
your heart you you wanna you want to
have like a ah
or or uh or you know these are the the
sounds of the feelings of compassion
like oh and so it's important to keep
tweaking the language until it hits
right and that's one of the things I
envision the mobile app is going to be
able to help us with and so you know the
inner allies as characters you know we
use pretty archetypes that are pretty
common in games and so forth
there was no kind of science behind
choosing the characters just the core
emotional needs but how I view them is
it's kind of like you know when you
dress up for Halloween and you put on a
costume all of a sudden you're you're
able to kind of do things you wouldn't
normally do and say things you wouldn't
normally say because it's not you right
you're now
you now have this other persona and so
with the inner allies it's kind of like
you can put on the persona of the inner
Ally and then speak to yourself in that
persona and it takes away that
awkwardness and that that fear of like
Oh like I'm not allowed to speak to
myself this kind there's something you
know the man was gonna fall on my head
if I am this nice to myself right and so
some of those misconceptions kind of
fade into the background because it's
you're working with an inner ally you're
not you you're not on your own yeah this
one is so relatable to everything that
we go through in life where it just
there's a feeling that comes up that is
that there's some sort of like a persona
or some sort of like a thought or motion
that were maybe not aware of that comes
into our lives into our worldview and it
somehow triggers us to say some sort of
feeling of disconnectedness from other
people or disconnectedness just in
general and then what I love doing at
that point is I do really put on like an
interconnect in this persona at that
time and it just it's like a oneness
persona that kicks in is like are you
really gonna be in that state right now
or do you really believe in the one and
like it really helps me get back to the
one and it's it's like to really be able
to have a true authentic dialogue with
yourself and make it a part of like a
beautiful process like a oneness
superhero that you get to like call in
and like engage with and I love that so
it's something that maybe if you know if
we had children that had oneness
superheroes yeah yeah that could be
world-changing very fast I love that
oneness superheroes love it oh it's so
then hit us with them the future of
where you see this going well
so you know I have been playing around
with this in my coaching office and and
working with my clients on it
and I'm in San Antonio Texas right now
and our tuck scene is about seven years
old it's about as old as I am from my
enlightenment moment and so I have tried
with a sweat equity team and I've tried
in a variety of different ways to raise
funding locally and haven't been able to
kind of get it off the ground and so one
of the reasons I'm here at this
conference I'm gonna be pitching
inter-allied tomorrow is that I am ready
to get this product into the marketplace
and I know that I am the content expert
and that I need a team of people and the
people here are just truly amazing like
the skills and the insights like it's
yeah it's just a so nice to learn so
much from everyone and and to to sit at
the table and be a part of a team and
know that everybody is like one you know
that's actually one of the things that's
practiced in this community is how do
you run an ethical company how do you
run a business that is that treats
people well right that people feel held
and and I mean that is amazing to me and
so I can't think of a better place to be
looking for partners to bring this to
fruition like and this is one of the
things that's happening is you know
we're at the point now where mindfulness
has broken through into the popular you
know everybody knows about it and if
people are beginning to understand that
mindfulness and meditations are critical
skills to flourishing and I know the
research for self compassion actually is
even stronger than for mindfulness in
terms of well-being Wow it is it is like
coasting about five years behind the
wave of mindfulness research in the US
and so now is the time to build the
digital product because it's coming and
I want to have these tools available for
people i won
to hit the Millennials and Gen Z so that
you know imagine if I had emotional
fitness if I had practiced with my inner
allies like if I knew what my core
emotional needs were and how I could
meet them both with my inner language
and in my life and relationships you
know running into the trauma that we all
inevitably run into right and it's some
in some form what would that have looked
like if I had if I was emotionally fit
yeah right and that's what I would
really love to see for our young people
today let's give them let's give them
some tools so that so you know they've
got a fighting chance and we know that
depression and suicide and anxiety are
all skyrocketing as CDC just put out of
study that was a decade long and showed
that the suicide rate among young people
between 10 and 24 went up 56% and it is
continuing to trend upwards and so now
is the time
so this deploying inner ally to
especially Millennials and Gen Z this is
going to be in like a freemium style
where it's like a free download and then
there's additional that you that people
can subscribe to yeah yeah okay well you
know when I I the first time I pitched
this idea it was in 2013 and you know
calm and headspace where to very leaders
in the market now you didn't he didn't
exist or they were not popular yet it
was so interesting when you mentioned
that the efficacy of self compassion
versus mindfulness and meditation that's
a fascinating stat that I think can get
deeper especially personalized feedback
around self compassion and what that
does for well-being in comparison that's
a really interesting stat well I think I
mean the in 2003 I think maybe it was
the first Western medicine article
published on self compassion and and
it's just gone like whoosh like the
research has taken off and self
compassion and so now you're seeing it
like hot can we address burning out with
self compassion you know how all these
different things and I of course I'm
interested in addressing addiction and
helping people in recovery as well I
really would love anyone tuning in
please please please support Cynthia
please support in our ally please
support them as much as you can as you
can will would love to have this in our
world as fast as possible I love it
thank you so much I have some more
questions that I want to ask on the way
out do you know I have my cards with me
would you want me to get my physical
cards so I can show them to the camera
there's 16 of them though they all don't
have to come to the party I just have a
subset of the inner allies here this one
is actually my favorite this is the
grandmother grandma and so this was the
very first inner ally voice that I had
in my head and this is a superpower for
the grandmother is nurturing yeah you
know and when I say superpower I'm
talking about core emotional needs yeah
but I don't want to use that terminology
like you know with the application
because I really wanted to be accessible
I don't want it to sound scary and
oftentimes when people hear core
emotional need they think oh it's needy
but it's actually more like I need water
it's something you really need to
flourish and so with this card we can
talk about what would the grandmother
what would it sound like if you spoke to
yourself and the voice of the
grandmother yeah
and then what they do on the other side
is lined and they would write out their
their own personalized customized way
that the grandmother would speak and
oftentimes it's situational because
people are struggling with a particular
situation and so it's customized around
that situation as well yes yes and so
the grandmother alright my friend so
have the lover where's the superpower of
intimacy okay we have the cheerleader
and where the superpower is worthiness
ooh
worthiness and we have the citizen where
the superpower is community mm-hmm they
have the companion where a superpower is
support and the captain where the
superpower is freedom mmm
the monk whose superpower is serenity
and this is this is one of my core
emotional needs the knight who's
superpower is security interesting and
that's the subway whoa so this is 8 8 of
the 16 of the 16 the night security the
monk serenity the captain freedom the
companion support the citizen community
the cheerleader worthiness the lover
intimacy and the grandmother nurturing
so beautiful love these so the so the
future is when we feel like we have some
sort of a an emotional need that's not
being met we can be gained this
assistance from something like inner
Ally and and feel the grandmother feel
the citizen feel the night and and that
can really activate that maximize our
well-being I love this an easier way to
access what's already in you like we
really already have the ability to meet
our our core emotional needs
but nobody's taught us and and also
sometimes we feel like we don't have
permission yes yes um okay the last last
question that I can add that I can ask
you on the program they're both very
short questions the first one is do you
believe that the root of all of our
issues in our world is due to our
feelings of separation you know normally
my answer is is fear
I think I think separation in fear are
probably go hand in hand because you
know we're human and you know we are
literally pack animals we know that if
somebody goes out into isolation they
actually shorten their lifespan and
there's all kinds of bad health
repercussions and so that would be the
ultimate fear right is isolation from
community and so yeah I think you're
right you're saying yeah I love those
two together fear in separation being
the root of the main issue so it's all
about getting to the roots that's why we
ask the question not the symptoms the
roots and then catalyzing feelings of
interconnectedness and all the other
things that we need last question is
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in life yeah I think the most
beautiful thing is that sense of
expansion that you get and it comes in
many ways it comes when you learn
something new it comes when you realize
that you're more than what you realized
you were it comes when you realize when
it can come in relationship right when
all of a sudden you realize like ah I
love that person it's that that I think
that's really the most amazing thing
yeah oh thank you thank you for this
incredible episode thanks for coming on
the show and teaching us about what
you're doing dinner a lie and emotional
fitness thank Cynthia it's such my
pleasure
I'm happy to be here and to share I want
other people to experience what I have
been able to yeah and what a cool way to
democratize it I love it I love it and
hopefully like it we said everyone
please do support in our ally however
you can get supporting as much as you
can you find the links in the bio below
to that also
check out the links in the biota
transformative technology conference
check out their ecosystem links all
those links are in the bio below an
incredible partnership for us again
Thank You Brady for co-producing with us
we greatly appreciate it thank you very
much and also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organizations around the world that you
believe in in your community support
simulation can find all of our links
below our PayPal patreon crypto-currency
links are down there you can design cool
merch and get paid all those links are
down there and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world you love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
bye everyone peace
[Music]
you
[Music]